hello everybody what's going on welcome
to another Bitcoin trading and investing
video while I talk I'm going to have a
brief trading session from last night
going on in the background it's about
like a 30-minute session but I'll speed
it up to match the videos time so to go
a little quicker so as usual this video
is intended for educational use only so
read the text warning before the video
started before you proceed with the rest
of the video so what I want to talk
about here is what I've learned in my
brief dealings with Bitcoin so far so
first off actually getting your hands on
some Bitcoin can prove to be somewhat
tedious so no one really trusts anyone
and a lot of the websites to first sell
you your Bitcoin are super sketchy that
said there are kind of two or three ways
to kind of get started
safely I would say so if you're from the
United States or a place that uses a the
same number of bank account numbers and
routing numbers then you should
definitely go with coinbase comm
European friend of mine couldn't
actually do that though because coinbase
want you to put in a nine digit routing
number where Europe uses I banner
international bank account number so you
can't for whatever reason it just
doesn't work in coin basis and at the
time of me making this video working
with that so I would say the best option
is coin based if you can the second best
option or second easiest option
something like local bitcoins calm or
something like that you can pay there
with a variety of means even PayPal but
even if you pay with PayPal there's like
a massive surcharge right because PayPal
is so easily charged back and people do
so you're basically paying for that
person's insurance right so so many
people charge back so they need to
charge you know such a rate that the
charge backs can be priced in to the
fact that they're dealing business on
PayPal so that's that I won't spend too
much time there because where you can
get Bitcoin changes so frequently on
where you should get bitcoins going to
change so frequently there's not real
too much point to talking much about it
you can also sign up for Mount Cox tie
your bank account and do that but it
takes about two weeks
so once you've got your Bitcoin now what
do you want to do right well the next
thing you need to do is is probably get
a personal wallet you don't really need
one but a personal wallet and or in
exchange that you want to work with it's
a pretty good idea to keep your idle
coins in like a personal wallet stored
on your own computer where it's nice and
safe but that said if you're planning to
trade them then you're going to probably
be leaving them in your account at least
with btc-e you can one make a nice
password and two you can have a phone
verification so every time you log in
you're gonna have to use Google
Authenticator to authenticate your
account and then every time you change
any account settings transfer all that
kind of stuff you can also have it
verify your account so it's very nice in
that way obviously though if you lose
your phone you are boned so keep that in
mind so don't lose your phone so now the
other thing that you can do is like if
you wanted to just leave coins and maybe
just like store them and forget about a
meeting you want maybe some coins you
want to trade with but some coins you're
just going to keep you can even store
them literally in on paper but we'll get
to that in a second so when it comes to
wallets on your computer if you want to
have one it really depends on like what
kind of a thing you're after right
because like some of the popular ones
like multi-bit bitcoin queue teen like
armory but each of those has their own
like benefits and in kind of downsides
depending on what you're after so like
and then also the the wallets that
you're going to use on your computer
they're going to change fairly
frequently right and I wouldn't just
choose any ones and and I would only
download from a reputable site so
there's a lot of fraud so I'll include
some some of the proper links in the to
the websites and the few programs that
I'll even mention they'll be in the
description and like at least for now
some of the popular ones like Bitcoin
cutie is probably one of the most
popular it's a full feature one but the
problem is it uses up a lot of space on
your hard drive and a lot of memory as
it runs
then you've got multi-bit which is kind
of like the opposite of that it doesn't
use really any space you're not going to
download the entire blockchain and all
this and then you've got armory which is
kind of like a happy medium between the
two of them but all of them are pretty
good I suggest you just download them
all and just try them and see which one
you actually like yourself so once you
have the wallet program now you want to
find in that program whatever your
address is so if you wanted somebody to
send you bitcoins or you want it to
transfer some bitcoins you transfer them
to that address same thing if you're on
an exchange well but we'll talk about
that in a second as well and also
remember that you should always password
protect your wallets and then really the
security of that wallet is only as good
as that password and don't forget that
password right so as you'll find over
time bitcoin is extremely unforgiving if
you lose your password or you lose your
hard drive you're just screwed that's
that there's no customer support and a
lost-and-found
there's plenty stories of people like
losing their hard drives with hundreds
of bitcoins on them right so don't
become a story you can somewhat protect
yourself by backing up your wallets too
so if you have you know hundreds and
hundreds of dollars or thousands or
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
Bitcoin it would make sense for you to
go ahead and backup your wallet on one
to three hard drives and maybe even
store one of your hard drives in like a
safety deposit box or something like
that just in case a fire or something
like that so there's that and then again
like I was saying with paper wallets so
if you think your account has maybe a
key logger on it or some sort of trojan
or anything like that what you're going
to want to do is use one of these paper
wallets and so i don't expect anybody
needs a paper wallet right now but just
know that they exist and you you can
just you get the program to do it and
just remember as you do it
unplug your computer from the internet
and probably never plug it back in again
until you wipe the hard drive so that's
that just keep that in mind for the
future if you need it so now that you've
got your wallet now you need an exchange
right and so that's the next step is
you've got to find an exchange
well everyone pretty much knows about
Mount GOx that's usually the first
exchange you find when you're looking
for them but my worry about Mount GOx is
they appear at least right now to be
under a lot of regulatory pressure so
you know back in in 2011 is when Mount
[ __ ] pretty much became the Bitcoin
exchange right mount Cox was originally
like I was talking about before Magic
the Gathering online exchange and then
it was turned into a big coin exchange
now earlier I mentioned that I wasn't
sure who started the Bitcoin thing if it
was the original you know Magic the
Gathering owner or if it was the new guy
that bought the website but it was
actually indeed the original owner Jed
McCaleb that made it but then he real
recent will or not recently well early
on in the infancy of being a Bitcoin
exchange sold it to this guy Marc carp
Ellis pretty much the same year he made
it that was back in 2011 and then from
there mount GOx evolved into really the
biggest exchange but it is no longer I
believe the biggest exchange and this
mark carp Ellis guys estimated to be
worth about 200 to 250 million ish
dollars just depends on the extremely
widely varying price of Bitcoin pretty
much so and that's just with his you
know bank account and Bitcoin right so
if you add in and it added in the value
of his business probably a lot more but
that's the problem as they say doing it
big will put you on the map and it did
so in 2013 alone money's been seized in
frozen from Mount Cox under the claim
that mount Cox is operating a financial
exchange while not actually having
proper registration and filling out the
proper paperwork
so because of this mount GOx has been
having a really hard time especially
recently and pretty much impossible
recently getting money to us users also
European and Canadian users as well so
then what right well well what you can
do is you can put your money in mount
gosh you can put your your bitcoins in
mount GOx and because matt GOx isn't
alone in the regulatory pressure btc-e
is also under pressure and starting to
have problems as well pretty much any
exchange that gets popular
they hasn't filed the proper paperwork
is going to get attacked and even if
they have file the proper paperwork
they're going to get attacked they
better have money for lawyers and all
that and that's no surprise that this is
happening and I do plan to get into this
more but you will have to decide whether
or not you have faith that the Bitcoin
system can survive the fight against the
coming regulatory pressure that is just
pretty much going to occur right and at
least for now the best solution that I
can give you guys is you know you can
have your Bitcoin wherever you want
pretty much that's pretty easy to
transfer around usually that you can
transfer your Bitcoin around within you
know thirty minutes usually even without
a fee it's very quick but what if you
want your money wherever you are in your
exchange sell your bitcoins
I mean sell your US dollars for Bitcoin
move that Bitcoin to coinbase cash out
at coin base that's your best bet at
least right now but again that can
totally change and if you if you can't
use coin base in your country then you
would use something like local Bitcoin
or um I don't know even something like
Craigslist to sell your Bitcoin but
hopefully you can use coin base and coin
base is a US company based in Silicon
Valley so San Francisco California
they're properly registered and it just
got backed by some important people so
I'll be talking more about that as well
in the future but just keep that in mind
that is happening at the moment so far
coin base has done things right they are
very big already they appear to be on
solid ground I haven't heard too much
bad stuff about them so that's that so
then now what let's talk about trading
so what exchange do you go with and why
well personally I went with btc-e
to start playing with Bitcoin I chose
this for a variety of reasons the main
reason is because well well other than
not the main reason but part of the
reason was I was a little worried about
mountain ox and their issues I don't
know anything about them I don't know
for certain if they'd be able to
withstand or you know quote-unquote run
on the bank so to speak along with that
the main reason I went btc-e
is because they have a superior API and
I knew that I wanted to do algorithmic
trading and make like a trade bot with
it and so I kind of chose btc-e just
because their API was much better now at
the time of me writing this the mount
Cox API is completely down and has been
down for like 20 hours so that's kind of
annoying and it so it turns out that I
was completely right so it wasn't the
case at the time that mount Cox API was
going down so much but but it's now I'm
I'm pretty happy that I didn't choose
them but also mount GOx is a lot more
volatile their fees are higher and so on
so it just seemed to make a lot of sense
to first go with btc-e just because it
seemed like a much safer route to learn
the ins and outs of the bitcoin industry
so obviously with volatility higher and
the price is higher it is somewhat
people for talking the popular for
people to talk about arbitrage I haven't
tried it and I do hear a lot of people
talking about it but I do find it iffy
because I mean how could the price be so
much higher I really don't know maybe
just because getting your transferring
out of mount Cox takes a lot of time or
transferring Bitcoin into mount GOx
takes a lot of time or maybe it's just
the time it takes to get your account
verified for trading on Mount Cox I
really don't know I do plan to attempt
it though and I will all let you all
know like what what happened I guess if
I'm like really silent on it I'm making
a lot of money so so that's that anyway
so I did go with btc-e that's what you
can see me trading with in the
background at least here the trades are
really fast I mean there seems to be
almost no delay we're probably thinking
like 100 millisecond or something with
registering offers cancelling offers and
even crediting your transactions that
have occurred so definitely a solid
exchange so far with what I've done so
my only complaint with them so far is
the fees seemed kind of weird some
trades I pay a fee on some I don't at
first I thought it'd be to 0.2% because
that's what they say is 0.2% but they
don't really make it clear if that's on
every buy every sell both and so I
initially thought
it would be 2.2 percent on everything
and then I started trading and I wasn't
getting it on buys so then I was like
okay it's point 2 percent on all the
cells but sometimes I pay that sometimes
I don't pay any fee at all sometimes I
pay it both ways
it's really odd to say the least so I
wouldn't suggest that you assume that
it's anything I would just assume 0.4%
right both ways so so like let's say the
price is 850 you got to make you know
between three and four dollars margin
just purely on the fees alone and then
go from there right and so like my first
day of trading I was trading with like
twenty five dollars worth of Bitcoin and
I thought you know okay I made a couple
of dollars but really I only made like
20 cents at first and then I actually
lost about ten cents so I don't think
that the fees are random but I don't
understand when they're coming into play
and when they're not and I'm not sure
maybe if it has something to deal with
like the calculator or something I just
I have no idea what it is so if you
happen to know feel free to comment
below why why it appears that their fees
are completely random and I do know at
least like on Mount GOx for example the
fees will change based on volume so if
you make a higher vault like it starts
at 0.6 but the more volume you're
trading the less it becomes so there is
that so that is that personally you can
see my trading setup how I've kind of
been doing I can talk more on that later
but you pretty much see what's going on
there it just allows me to make really
quick trades when I need to so there is
a lot of sitting time I'm not really
high frequency trading by any means
sometimes I sit for as long as five 10
15 20 minutes even but a lot of times
you're going to see extreme volatility
especially when someone doesn't mass buy
or a mass sell there's a opportunity
there to make some quick quick money so
it is helpful
it does help obviously if you have
multiple monitors so you can just put
you know that on one monitor and then do
whatever you do on your computer on your
other monitors on so you're not really
just like sitting there like twiddling
your thumbs because it
it's really easy to get antsy if you're
just staring at price and doing nothing
else but as long as you can be doing
other things like I'm usually
programming or doing something else
while I'm doing this so I'm not getting
like Nancy to make trades or impatient
so anyway that's that with btc-e
whenever you successfully do make a
trade it will ding but that ding isn't
always very timely sometimes it doesn't
tell you for you know 5-10 minutes that
you until you've made a trade right so
that can be kind of problematic for you
depending on what kind of trading you're
doing now at least with their API though
you can't connect and so like what I
ended up doing was connecting to the API
and I just my script makes a noise
python script makes a sound when the
price hits or exceeds or hits or goes
below a certain value so it makes a
noise on my computer and that is very
timely it's instantly right so it's very
helpful there so that keeps me updated I
can show you guys how to do something
like that as well so I'll probably do
that and include that in a video so stay
tuned there so anyways hopefully that's
been helpful for you some of you guys to
get started if you want in the next
video I'll be talking a bit about the
long term prospects of Bitcoin at least
from me I'm training Bitcoin but my
intention is really to trade Bitcoin and
build up Bitcoin not dollars so for the
most part every time I end a trading
session I make sure I actually i'm
holding Bitcoin right I'm not leaving
without holding Bitcoin that's probably
the opposite of what a lot of people are
doing and maybe even what you're doing
but that's my goal and I'm basically
simultaneously long Bitcoin so I
intended to just continue building up
Bitcoin and holding Bitcoin and then
doing some trading on the side
especially testing with the machine
trading so that's that so if you're
interested in hearing my Bitcoin
prospects video stay tuned for the next
video if you do like my videos enough on
Bitcoin there is a Bitcoin donation
address in the description otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until the next video